كانت أول رحلة خارجية للرئيس دونالد ترامب الليلة على الأقل إلى المملكة
العربية السعودية إشارة إلى
أنه بصرف النظر عن خطاباته المتعثرة ، قد يكون في الواقع يصل
إلى هذه الزاوية المضطربة من العالم ،
يتم متابعة كل كلمة له عن كثب هنا في
لبنان حيث تجري المنافسات الإقليمية والعالمية.
تفاصيل
السياسة المحلية منتقد قاس لنا
كان المعلق السياسي في الشرق الأوسط مارو
عثمان يأمل أن يفي ترامب
بوعده بسحب أمريكا
أولاً عندما زار المنطقة
وغير رأيه بشأن المغادرة
لأنه قال إنه يريد المغادرة يجب أن
تغادر الشرق الأوسط وهذا ما نحن عليه
نريد جميعًا أن نسمع أننا نريد أن نترك
وشأننا لم يحدث ذلك منذ أن أصبح
رئيسًا ، فقد عكس عقودًا من
السياسة الأمريكية واعترف بالقدس
كعاصمة لإسرائيل ألغت الاتفاق النووي الإيراني
وأعاد تطبيق العقوبات الصارمة
، وعاد إلى المملكة العربية السعودية في فندق هيلتون
إنها حرب اليمن  في
مخيم شاتيلا للاجئين الفلسطينيين ، موقع مجزرة عام 1982 ،
قام ماجد مسئول في
حركة فتح
بملاحقة الحكام العرب الذين قفزوا على
متن قطار ترامب ولكن الرئيس الأمريكي في الغالب
يترك هؤلاء اللاجئين من الجيلين الثالث والرابع
وليس كلهم ، هذا هو مح
ل دونالد أوفوت هندي.  يم
علامات عالية للتخلي عن الصفقة الإيرانية ، فمن
البداية أن أقول للجمهورية هل
الجمهورية الإسلامية الإيرانية توقف ولا
فقط من أجل الصفقة النووية التي توقفت عن العمل في
جميع أنحاء المنطقة ، توقف عن
توسيع إمبراطوريتك من العراق إلى سوريا
إلى لبنان إلى فلسطين إلى اليمن
في شارع الحمرا في بيروت.
بلا أدنى شك في أن رئيس
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية يهتم بما
يقوله أي شخص هنا كل البوق
البوق من داني كيف تصفع
بعين لا تشوبها شائبة إنه سؤالي الجيد بن
ويدمان سي إن إن بيروت.